i've chosen the number 153 or 153
because it's very special to me because
it's a narcissistic number to be a
narcissist then you need to basically be
in love with yourself
and 153 is in love with itself because
it has a mathematical property which
makes it so well you're fixing your hair
there can i ask you are you a narcissist
um
i think all mathematicians are a little
bit of a narcissist we're all in love
with ourselves
so a rubbish pen
one
can i change pens
five
three
well i can't see why that number's in
love with itself
hang on now depending on how many digits
the number has so this has one two three
digits
i'm going to take each of those digits
and raise it to that number 1 to the
power 3
to the power 3
and 3 to the power 3.
and i'm going to add those together so
i've got 1 cubed one cube's pretty
simple it's 1
5 cubed 1 two five
that requires a little bit more
mathematical knowledge
three cubes is twenty-seven
so we add them up
low and behold we'll get one add one two
five is one two six
add on 27 and we get
one
five
three
a number that is in love with itself
let me give you a four-digit
narcissistic number
eight two
zero eight
okay this time there are four digits to
a narcissistic number so four's the
important part that's what we're going
to raise each of these numbers to the
power so let's take 8 to the power 4
2 to the power 4
0 to the power 4 and 8 again to the
power 4. add these up in your head or
using a trusty calculator lo and behold
you get eight
two
zero eight check it at home
it's the same number
it's in love with itself is this useful
or important or is this just is this
just fun and games for you this is just
fun and games this is just one area of
why maths is so brilliant there is a
limit there are 88 narcissistic numbers
to be precise the largest is a very big
number that i can't actually say there's
too many things but the the most it has
is 39 places to that number so you can't
get any numbers bigger than 39 numbers
within it